não é todo dia que se apresentado pelo
be o gate do alto santo
olá
é uma satisfação alegria enorme está no
texas fortaleza e poder compartilhar com
cada um de vocês a fortaleza dos meus
olhos eu sou mais a vasconcellos como
dito no cordel
sou jornalista para alguns esse
investiga o livro da televisão mas pra
outros aquela roupa nas redes sociais é
eu uso mais na blogosfera também
prorrogou dos tempos dinossáurico da
blogosfera então vocês me encontram
também
aliás minha bill no twitter ainda é
quando eu nasci não tinha internet só de
mau bloco tuíto flicka e namora em pé
sobre a nova gripe a gente deixa para a
próxima à eu nasci lá exato e 52 anos a
itapipoca que é como os cearenses que
nascem na itapuca chama a itapipoca é eu
venho de um distrito de nome matinhas
meus amigos brincam dizendo que quem
nasce numa localidade como essa um
pontinho quase perdido no maps distante
130 quilômetros não vou em linha reta
até aqui
quem nasce no lugar com essa denominação
traz consigo uma marca e eu quero crer
que é assim mesmo eu acho que de repente
vai que um anjo que ele está bem em
tópicos que visitou o poeta quando eu
nasci a boquinha da noite no dizer de
uma mãe numa rede dentro de uma rede à
luz de lamparina veio esse anjo veio
todo disse vai mais a cp ladeira por
este mundo e eu cresci achando isso que
eu ia cruzar fronteiras ea pisar o chão
conhecer outras gentes ganha mundo mesmo
né
aquele ímpeto de adolescente me dizia
isso ninguém tinha dois anos ea minha
família ripple
para a capital e fortaleza nessa época
uma cidade de pouco mais de 500 mil
habitantes 500004 dali por diante
500 mil e 5 506 507 a família crescer um
pouquinho como se vê cresceu mais do que
se vê aqui e daí veio a maturidade e eu
me peguei tachando raízes gostando
inclusive a espalhadas dando frutos
eu fui ficando nunca saí daqui de fato
fortaleza é a cidade que o hábito desde
sempre e é a cidade que me habita
mas nos tempos recentes eu amuo fynei
para dizer um termo muito nosso até um
desencanto um desalento e eu só pensava
em sair daqui de repente jogar sem fazer
bullying como agente dias nada ontem
cheio de memórias de histórias e me
jogar pra amanhã
desconhecidos sair no dia 1º de janeiro
de 2015 o meu dia do fico de verdade eu
olhei disse o seguinte que é isso que
vai desistir é uma mulher do sertão não
é assim né
e eu decidi que ao invés de i&d sair
daqui eu iria pergulho ar nessa cidade
de fato uma cidade que eu nem conhecia
e foi daí que surgiu o fortaleza 365
olhado o site essa inquietação não do
apavoramento por favor não
mas aquele é o fundamento que eu falei
tá pouco então disse eu vou fazer alguma
coisa
mergulhar nessa cidade significa lançar
um olhar sobre ela e foi exatamente isso
que eu fiz eu nesse insight tas em um
perfil e uma na verdade do que viria a
ser esse projeto é a vontade de
mergulhar e aí eu disse é eu vou me dar
uma tarefa uma boa e estipular uma meta
pra mim mesma e criei lá abril do perfil
em 2015 uma imagem todo dia na fortaleza
que se transfigura
do celular a cidade que quer ser um
ótimo já não é um olhar alguém alguma
memória e é isso exatamente a minha
proposta não tinha uma pretensão dizer
um estudo não tinha pretensão de ser uma
reportagem é não tinha pretensão de
buscar a fundamentação era um antes de
tudo um exercício de afetividade e isso
é de fato que foi o projeto do começo
até o fim
o ponto de partida era a casa da minha
infância foi o quintal cheio de pé de
planta o quintal dos domingos de céu
azul do alarido da meninada da periferia
e se quintal com os telhados em
patchwork esse foi o ponto de partida
era a vontade de abrir a janela para
mundos em movimentos e dizer eu quero
entender mais nessa cidade eu quero
conhecer mais a cidade eu quero misturar
com ela uma cidade que nem sempre é
reconhecida pelos seus próprios
habitantes como metrópole que é então a
minha vontade era instigar esse
conhecimento da diversidade e
grandiosidade da nossa capital partindo
daí eu de fato disse
vou vou abrir agora quando você por
exemplo é está em busca da sua cidade de
um ideal de cidade eu usava é a hashtag
minha fortaleza eu tava querendo mais ou
menos admitir que existe o ideal de
cidade é algo que de alguma forma
mantinha uma ordem anterior
e quando você pisa o chão da rua você
encontra o outro você encontra o
controverso e aquela casa minha casa no
lugar de acolhimento mantenedor dessa
ordem ela se desfez porque quando você
olha de fato você percebe que é preciso
ampliar as leituras casa por exemplo a
nossa casa o nosso lá a nossa vidinha
então não é do jeito que a gente quer
pode ser por exemplo a praça pra mim
os que cansados do corpo do peso da
cidade
deitam e dormem na praça na praça
oficina do senhor
a placa dizia aqui fabricar munições um
poste pode fazer pensar o que é casa o
andré quintino do projeto vendido ele
pega essas placas de imobiliária e
transforma em casas de passarinho
a casa de passarinho uma coisa tão
absurda porque ela pode trazer pra gente
o sentimento de como nós nos
distanciamos da natureza
essa casa ela já não existe mais no
lugar onde estava
ele coloca justamente lugares
abandonados desocupados está também
lembrar que a casa que já esteve ali
guardam memórias guarda estava histórias
e faz pensar sobre a especulação
imobiliária porque está abandonada
porque está desocupada a rua pode ser a
última morada
essa cruz quase invisível na thompson
bulcão e eu gostaria de pensar que
alguns de vocês já enxergou essa cruz
quase invisível ela fala sobre ivo vivo
nascido em 1960 morto em 2013
que histórias de dor justificam essa
eternidade fincada sob a sombra do
cajueiro
certamente a história fala de saudade e
saudade eu encontrei no casarão da tammo
zica a general sampaio no centro da
cidade levada pela mão por um amigo
conhece maria teresa e maria helena de
84 94 anos elas definitivamente guardam
volteios uma música que a gente nem
imagina que ali naquele lugar e elas
guardam vivências lembranças de mais de
um século
ali naquele casaram quando o avô arlindo
contínuo construiu o lar da família em
nessa casa viveu parede luís onde a
primeira
o pianista do ceará saudade alimento
todos os dias e aí nesse percurso
venho sentindo 100 local certo eu vou
encontrando um outro patchwork
esse tecido por uma postura muito
sensível a cidade me diz que tem
lamentos eu paro pra ouvir essa cidade
que se transfigura que tem tanto lixo
nas esquinas que tem desigualdade demais
embora tenha muitos sonhos
tá dito essa cidade reclama de
despedidas 34 casos apartamento não dar
lugar a um empreendimento imobiliário
quantas histórias ficaram para trás no
residencial iracema
essa esquina não é mais a mesma
nem vestígio do primeiro hotel cinco
estrelas de fortaleza construída em 1978
aqui já não há mais a sombra dessas
árvores uma quadra inteira na pereira de
miranda
elas agora vão duda tá lugar um
paisagismo que combina com a sua
natureza a cidade que se quer ouvir
téc eu retribuo conversa como quem quer
se fazer presente teu passado te olha se
trata de liberdade e silêncio surra que
grilhões de prendem cidade dependência
das esquinas de ruas e praças e com
respostas cidade criança certamente mais
em saber onde eu tô falando e o tempo
esse malino ele está em cada esquina
mesmo lembrando a gente de tudo aí tempo
paula diz que as esquinas são como
suspensões do tempo e usac ampliando
esse sentido quase ponto e vírgula para
falar do agora e do desafio de buscar a
cidade através da fotografia
não sou fotógrafo fez por outra eu me
encontro neste exercício de forma
confortável registrando estes momentos
como por exemplo está perdida no lagamar
wii
assim
a cidade se mostra uma tela
impressionista justo nessas horas que a
gente se deixa pará
ela fala dos limites quase outra cidade
quase noite quase não consegui voltar
pra casa ela fala aquele pedido quase
implícito por proteção
quantos de nós pedimos ela fala da
invisibilidade
quem vê o homem equilibrista sobre o
viaduto da santos dumont
quem vê a vida viaduto as cruzes são
todos os dias
nesses momentos eu parava diante do
espelho a me perguntar aqui exercício é
isso que estou fazendo que experiência
que eu quero guardar de fato
aí de repente eu parava e me via
aplicando cartão postal e olha a
resposta era boa as pessoas gostem
diversidade limpinha e alinhada pronta
para ser vendida na estrada bonita para
o outro mas não é exatamente isso que eu
queria olhar para a cidade
definitivamente buscar à cidade buscar a
si mesmo e o que eu vou encontrar
precisa de alguma forma dizer de mim o
que tem de identificação entre você e em
uma esquina de fortaleza
bom pode ser que muito pode ser que nada
eu digo a você que um dos encontros mais
fortes desse percurso aconteceu comigo
no cruzamento da rua padre valdevino com
a barão de studart
de repente eu voltei para dentro um
quarto escuro o corpo ardendo febre
olhos em shama cabelos arrancados do
couro era grande epidemia de sarampo ali
eu conheci de assis
evanildo de assis tinha 11 anos e teve
rogar pela caridade das ruas da cidade
ele tinha 1 ano e 8 meses quando talvez
dentro de um quarto escuro junto com uma
penca de irmãos arde em febre olhos em
chamas
cabelo talvez arrancado do couro era
grande epidemia de sarampo e cada vez
que eu caminhava eu encontrava gente
sabia que de verdade essa doidinha
cidade não vê essas pessoas que de fato
são a verdadeira construção do cotidiano
dessa resistência cidade silviana um
celeiro vindo do canindé
aos sete anos ele aprendeu o ofício até
hoje exercida quem comprou células de
animais eles 20 e espera sentado ali na
sua singela como quem tece prece para
francisco e olha francisco tenho certeza
que se anima com seu pirita 60 anos
ganhando a vida como engraxate da caixa
ali na praça do ferreira é um homem que
sabe da vida assim
exeni essa mulher alfabética de tantas
delícias encerrou brasil todo dia ele
repete a rotina ele sai da casa que
nasceu em 1938 atravessa a rua de
paralelepípedo se posta rent a sua
história
quantas lembranças do pará avião seu
luiz
até hoje você chega lá e diz assim seu
luiz mirara meio pão precisar de uma
kombi com o lado o papel de embrulho
pode ter certeza no jogo de 3 na
pracinha
a bodega da minha infância eu quero
pedir um instante para e memória
homenagear três figuras maravilhosas que
já não estão conosco
audifax rios antonieta noronha e
cristiano cama
cada uma dessas pessoas pois esse
projeto crescer avolumar-se e me dá a
certeza de que existe uma cidade em cada
um de nós como disse noite pereira é a
dona nem se ela prova que dá pra puxar a
cadeira na calçada e sentar e conversar
foi assim que eu conheci lá no henrique
jorge
o seu raimundo pega o peixe de madrugada
todo o dia no mucuripe vai vendendo
luciano cavalcante que ver essa cidade
gente o branquinho maurinho lorival
germano religiosamente há dez anos jogam
esquartejado na praça da cidade 2000 eo
jogo depila da sapiranga existe
e as tardes do opaia a as lagoas
pare por favor olhe para aqueles
espelhos que às vezes falam de falta de
afeto
na verdade eles liberam vida fluida
multicolorida
mas pra ver essas coisas você tem que
mergulhar ricardo guilherme tem um texto
que eu usei aqui que diz somente
mergulhar é ver o rio somente mergulhar
é ver o rio e os meninos da barra sabem
disso
agora é o seguinte essa cidade troca
tudo o tempo todo como disse isabel
wallace
ela troca tudo menos o céu
esse céu infinito ali sobre as nossas
cabeças quase imutável reparado nisso
e essa aldeia que rumou para o leste
avança em vertical e me diz o tempo
inteiro nesse percurso que uma narrativa
não é suficiente para mostrá la
não não é e aí eu volto pro começo pra
esse mundo aberto pela janela ele entra
e ele mostra que se o mais que eu
caminhasse e eu caminhei por 70 bairros
da capital todas as regionais e eu me vi
hesitando os sentimentos eu vi
solidariedade houve encantamento eu vi a
alegria eu vi pesar eu vi é desapego
mas em nenhum momento eu vi indiferença
eu saio inteira desse projeto sabendo
que é indiferença não tá pra ter quando
você mergulha quando você pisa quando
você olha então é assim diferença é
caminho cortado para desamor e ea
certeza agora é que eu saí transformada
a cidade não era a mesma tampouco eu ia
foi bom saber que outras pessoas usaram
o projeto como norte apontado dali por
diante
elas passaram a retratar o seu bairro
elas passaram a também pisar o chão
o tento disse um dia desses que
fortaleza é igual à nossa
que ser que a vida aqui eu vá ter alguma
razão e eu queria cruzar fronteiras
conhecer outros universos outras gentes
outras culturas
de repente me vi conversando com a
cidade de fortaleza mulher eu te entendo
não te corpo eu te amo é muito ó e no
final das contas assim como foi a viagem
mais longa que você já fez uma semana
três meses a seis meses
pois eu mesma linha olhando para trás
com esse amor essa paixão que me ficou e
tantas outras transformações
eu fiz uma viagem que durou 365 dias
muito obrigado